des corps humains sensuelle qui semble
poser des peintures monotype corinne
cesca travaille sur une plaque de métal
sont gravure créant des modèles inédits
des oeuvres réalisées grâce à une
vieille presse artisanale
[Musique]
je travaille sur les émotions
en fait ce qui est ce que mon c'est la
diversité des émotions et je passe par
le corps je cherche un langage sur le
monotype pour un langage pour exprimer
dans le corps sur les inversions de deux
hanches la puissance de l'émotion aussi
en essayant de par exemple de partir à
un pied propulser la tête
corinne cesca découvre son amour pour
l'art en 2006 une pratique tardive qui
passe par un envoûtement une révélation
les stands lui permet aux possibilités
infinies de création c'est la technique
du monotype qui m'a
complètement séduit parce qu'on
travaille sur une plaque de métal on
peut enlever rajouter gradé s'est on
peut tout faire pour une feuille de
papier gratté par dessus j'ai le plaisir
du geste aussi quand il ya des rythmes
on peut partir de dans le mouvement
c'est la puissance c'est le moi qu'il
faut que j'inscrive quoi fonctions ce
qui me vient comme comme émotion sur ma
plaque un marc exutoire pour l'artiste
corinne c'est ce qu'a exposé ces trois
dernières années de création
[Musique]